you're single I went with a single value
site single stuck what's the name of it
vitamin D vitamin D yeah because you
know a lot of women out here they're
they're missing a lot of key nutrients
in their life I just I just want them to
stay very healthy out in these streets
so they need the proper dose of vitamin
D every day you know what I mean you get
it from sons yes son right yeah I get it
from sunshine and the crazy thing about
that is in order to get the proper dose
of vitamin D you have to have like 10
minutes on the front and you got to flip
over and get 10 minutes on the back hey
hey I'm not lying you guys gonna look
this up right this is real you're either
doing a great public service
announcement right now or you're a
disgusting person so here's the thing
I'd like to think that I'm somewhere
right in between with those things and
that is what Ludacris is all about yeah
also about talking about himself in the
third person
Conan's all about okay there was a
little bit of a controversy because for
the video for vitamin D yeah people were
saying you had CGI'd ABS let's take a
look at that picture right there now I
have no idea what they're talking about
that yeah I worked hard for that chest
in those ABS man yeah oh alt seven on
the computer right there I'm just truth
it doesn't look did you think you were
gonna get away with that
I knew 100% I would because this is
typical Ludacris behavior of anybody has
seen any of my videos this is 100% meant
to be I like having fun like you I hope
when people joke I don't take myself too
seriously
right Ludacris means beyond crazy why
all the ridiculousness yes all meant to
be so I'm giving people great
entertainment yes
well what's funny what's funny is first
of all I want them to get I love that
there's no attempt to make that look
realistic
looks like look like the airbrushing on
the side of a carnival rock but it's
also making me think why can't we have
that on this show you should dude how
much would it cost if I walk out and do
the top of the show why can't they put
that even over my suit you said you know
you said why can't I have a six-pack you
should do it yeah telling you did it
cost a lot of money it cost a little
something but you know that's what
separates me from all the other artists
out there I hate when people try to be
the same right you know what I mean you
got to know what I'm talking about right
you got a very unique
you